FRACESC CAMPOY: Hi,
and welcome to episode
number 82 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc Campoy.
And I'm here with my
colleague, Mark Mandel,
that is finally back.
Welcome back, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hi.
I'm am back.
Thank you.
FRACESC CAMPOY:
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I am very well.
I am well-rested, well-fed.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Well jet-lagged?
MARK MANDEL:
Actually, not too bad.
It's pretty good.
It's been pretty good.
Awesome.
Well, we are here this week
to talk all about Prometheus.
FRACESC CAMPOY:
Oh, that is cool.
And not only are we going
to talk about Prometheus,
but we actually going to
talk about it with one
of the creators, Julius Volz.
So he's going to be
joining us from Berlin,
and tell us about
what is Prometheus.
If you don't know
what it is, it's
basically a monitoring system.
MARK MANDEL: It's open source.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Yeah, that
is completely open source
and completely written in Go.
So yay.
MARK MANDEL: I knew
you'd like that.
Fantastic.
And then after we've
done that, we'll
have our regular question
of the week, where
we're talking about
logging, where
you haven't logged before.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That sounded very "Star Trek."
MARK MANDEL: I thought so.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So yeah, logging like
when you have not
written any log statements.
And now it's failing
in production.
What?
MARK MANDEL: Help.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So we'll talk about
that use case,
and how we can help with that.
But before that,
we have as always,
our cool things of the week.
First one that we have-- and I
keep running this in an order,
and then going over the things
in a completely different
order, but I don't care.
Because the most
exciting one for me
is that we have
a new region that
has been open for
Google Cloud platform.
And it is the Singapore
region, which is very exciting.
I have never been
to Singapore yet.
But there's a
[INAUDIBLE] Singapore,
so I might go next year.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRACESC CAMPOY: This
is going to make it
so the round trip for Google
data center in Southeast Asia
is going to be
much, much better.
So of course, Singapore.
But also, if you think
about places like Indonesia,
there's going to be a huge,
huge difference for them.
So we're very
excited about that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It looks really, really good.
Always glad to have
more locations.
We seem to be growing
them a lot lately,
which I'm super happy about.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah.
Because it makes
for more reasons
to travel around
and go visit places.
So that's exciting.
I mean, because it
helps customers.
That's what I was saying.
MARK MANDEL: That's
what you're saying.
Exactly.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Yeah, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
So going on from there, one of
the ones that I particularly
like in the machine
learning space is--
we recently talked
about and announced
the release of the TensorFlow
object detection API.
So the cool thing of
the week is actually
a tutorial about how you
can use this new open source
framework that makes object
detection much easier.
So if you want to be like,
hey, that thing's a car,
or that things a dog,
or that thing over there
is a fire hydrant, I don't know,
anything along those lines,
this is a tutorial
that shows you
how you can use that framework,
but specifically tying it
in with our cloud
machine learning engine,
our scalable fully
managed service
for doing this kind of
machine learning stuff.
And it's a really nice
step-by-step example
of how to do this and how to
build it all with TensorFlow.
But particularly what I love
about it is that it uses--
what's the exact name for it?
FRACESC CAMPOY: I
think it's the Oxford?
MARK MANDEL: I don't
know why it's the IIT.
But it's basically
a pet database.
So anything that involves
you using dogs or animals I'm
totally for.
So you get to look at
cute puppies and stuff
while you're actually training
your TensorFlow model.
FRACESC CAMPOY: I
really like that they
show a picture of two beagles.
And one is 99% beagle, and
the other one is 98% beagle.
So I'm wondering what is
the "beagliest" beagle
they can find.
MARK MANDEL: Well clearly,
the one on the left
is the "beagliest".
FRACESC CAMPOY: Clearly.
MARK MANDEL: Clearly
FRACESC CAMPOY: I
love TensorFlow.
And the examples that they
use, they're always hilarious.
I love it.
Finally, we have a third
cool thing of the week.
And it's a solution
from our solutions team
that is preparing
a container engine
environment for production.
And this is really cool, because
creating a container engine
cluster is incredibly simple.
You just go to the form,
click a button, that's it.
Or even from gcloud.
So it's super easy, right?
But that doesn't mean that
you should open that directly
to the world, and just
hope for the best.
There's a lot of
different best practices
that you should follow, like
from the point of view of IAM,
there you go.
IAM.
What are the rules that
you should be providing?
What roles the
machine should have.
What rules you should have.
And things like that.
How to protect the
machines using all the
firewalls, and stuff like that.
Basically, it's
mostly about security,
but it is very important.
And it has very
concrete examples.
So if you have a
container engine
cluster running in production--
and I would even say if you have
a Kubernetes cluster running
in production, most of
these best practices
definitely apply to you.
So go check it out.
And let us know what you think.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's really good guide
on a whole lot of
things from RBAC and IAM
through how to do
communications from your data
center to your cluster, and
all sorts of other stuff
from there.
So definitely worth
having a look at.
FRACESC CAMPOY:
If you do not know
what is a headless
service, you should
read, because it
actually explains it.
Because I did not
know what it was.
So if don't know what
it is, go check it out.
It's actually an
interesting thing
that may help you have a
better life in production.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well, why don't we go chat
with our friend Julius,
and have a talk all about
open source monitoring
with Prometheus.
FRACESC CAMPOY:
Sounds very good.
Let's do that.
So I'm very happy
to welcome today
Julius Volz, the
Prometheus co-founder.
Hello, Julius.
How are you doing?
JULIUS VOLZ: Hi,
I'm doing great.
Thanks for having me.
FRACESC CAMPOY: And you're
joining us from Berlin today?
JULIUS VOLZ: Yup.
Nice weather here.
6:40 PM.
The whole week will be
very nice and sunny.
FRACESC CAMPOY: That is awesome.
I met you a long time ago.
I think it was the first
talk Prometheus ever gave.
The Go meet up in Berlin.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
JULIUS VOLZ: Yup,
that's correct.
FRACESC CAMPOY: It's
been a long time.
So we're going to be talking
a little bit about Prometheus,
and what it is and everything.
But before we talk
about that, tell
us a little bit about yourself
and what you do at Prometheus.
So I guess the company is
also called Prometheus?
Or is it SoundCloud?
JULIUS VOLZ: Ha ha!
So there is no company.
That's the trick.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Oh.
Yeah, myself.
So I was a Google Site
Reliability Engineer
at some point in my career.
And then from Google, went
straight to SoundCloud.
From Zurich to Berlin.
And at SoundCloud, we
started building Prometheus.
So that's what I've been doing
for roughly the past five years
or so.
I left SoundCloud roughly
1 and 1/2 years back,
and then started doing just
freelancing around Prometheus.
Prometheus is a
monitoring system that
is really independent by now.
It's part of the Cloud
Native Computing Foundation,
which in turn is part
of the Linux Foundation.
Kubernetes was the
first project in there,
and we are the second.
So it means there's
no one company that
controls the project.
There are companies that
offer services around it,
but they are not the
main Prometheus company.
And SoundCloud doesn't even
care that much about Prometheus
anymore, although
it was born there.
MARK MANDEL: OK, so let
us talk about Prometheus.
At a high level, what is it?
What does it do?
What's its purpose?
JULIUS VOLZ: Right.
So Prometheus is a systems
monitoring tool kit slash
ecosystem.
Some years in the
past, there were
systems like Nagios, Graphite,
Ganglia, StatsD, Munin,
and so on.
Some for collecting time series.
Some for running checks to
actually send alerts to people.
And of course, these
tools still exist,
and they have their uses.
But they were created
in a world that
was way more static than
the infrastructure worlds
that we have nowadays,
where you have clusters,
like Kubernetes,
cluster managers that
schedule instances and plods
dynamically, moving around
a scaling up, scaling down.
And so, Prometheus is
a monitoring system
that was specifically built
for this kind of dynamic cloud
environment, where these
things are shifting around
all the time, and you
still want to try and make
sense of things.
And we started building
Prometheus really because--
so this was back in 2012.
Matt Proud and myself
joining SoundCloud,
both coming from Google,
having seen how you can
monitor dynamic environments.
And then being thrown
into a startup,
basically, SoundCloud--
which already
had a dynamic environment.
They had a dynamic
cluster scheduler,
but they still had the old
kind of monitoring tools.
And they were OK, but they
weren't really cutting it
anymore for this
kind of scenario.
So it was really
difficult to find out,
for example, if there
was a latency spike.
Was it only one instance?
Was it multiple?
Which instance was it?
The dimensionality of Graphite
wasn't really sufficient.
The alerting expressiveness,
and data model of Nagios,
and the lack of any history
in Nagios to alert on
was another problem.
And so, Prometheus was really
inspired by Google's approach
to monitoring.
And takes an approach of
let's collect everything
that we care about
in our infrastructure
as a set of metrics, as a
set of time series first.
And then base any dashboards
and alerts on these time series.
And to allow you to make
that powerful enough,
we also basically
added a query language
to Prometheus that
is quite flexible,
that allows you to work with
the data that you collected,
and formulate really powerful
expressions against the data.
To slice and dice the
data, aggregate up,
drill down, depending on
what you need in that moment.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So to give some more context,
and maybe for those people who
aren't as familiar for
monitoring and stuff,
could you give an
example of step-by-step
through what you
would be setting up,
and why you'd be setting
it up, and how would that
work with Prometheus?
JULIUS VOLZ: Yeah, there's
so many different ways
I could set things up.
Prometheus is really kind of a
Swiss army knife of monitoring.
Let's start with a
simple case of we
just want to gather host
metrics or note metrics.
Then we could install
a little component,
called the Note Exporter, which
is a agent on every machine.
And it will basically
fetch metrics
about the machine itself from
the proc and the sysfs file
systems.
And it has a little
HTTP endpoint
over which Prometheus,
the server,
can scrape metrics
from that host.
So you set up a
Prometheus server.
And you tell it, here
are all of my hosts
that I care about that
I want to monitor.
And it will then go out
to these Note Exporters
and will pull in a dimensional
data model all these metrics.
They will be tasked with
something we called labels.
They're key value
pairs on every metric
that tell you what service
the metrics came from, what
exact instance in
the service, and then
what other kind of
subdimensions they
pertain to, like the exact CPU
core for CPU usage or so on.
MARK MANDEL: And
then from there, you
can do stuff with it?
JULIUS VOLZ: Right.
So Prometheus stores that.
Prometheus is a
pull based system.
It pulls those
metrics from things
you care about,
like Note Exporters,
but also your services
or other things.
It stores them as
time series on disk.
And then you can use that
in three different ways
I would say.
Either for ad-hoc debugging,
you go to Prometheus itself.
It has a built-in UI for trying
out some Prometheus query
language, Prom QL expressions,
where you can really
inspect the current state
of all your infrastructure.
And once you have
expressions there
that you might want to
dashboard, you can use a tool,
like Grafana to talk to
Prometheus's HTTP API
to run the exact
same queries and have
nice persistent dashboards that
you can share with your team,
throw on the wall, and so on.
And then the third
use case would
be alerting, where you
can reuse the same query
language for
actually formulating
really precise alerts against
the data you collected.
MARK MANDEL: So I might be able
to set something up that says,
if my CPU's been at
95% for five minutes,
then send me an alert,
because something
is going wrong on the server
or something like that?
JULIUS VOLZ: Exactly.
Yep.
And you can do things that are
not even strictly threshold
related.
So for example, in Nagios, you
can only really say something
like, if this check script
fails three times in a row,
then alert me.
And you don't really
collect history first
that you can then do more
analysis over, right?
It doesn't collect
any time series data.
With Prometheus, you collect
basically some amount
of time series data.
And you can do some more
time-based analysis on it.
For example, you can say,
based on the last four
hours of the disk usage,
tell me whether my disk will
be full in four hours or
so, and then alert on that.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, I see.
So sort of predictive
analysis type things?
JULIUS VOLZ: So there's limited
forms of predictive analysis.
There's no automatic anomaly
detection, no kind of magic
there.
But it's explicit rules,
explicit functions
that allow you to go quite far.
FRACESC CAMPOY: So
that sounds really
interesting from the point of
view of like older features
that it offers.
But I'm curious about
how it actually runs.
So you mentioned that
it is pull-based system.
So you have a server
that is pulling
every single one of the jobs.
Does that mean that
you need to install
an agent in every
single one of your jobs.
What does that look like?
JULIUS VOLZ: So it
does mean that you
do have to have HTTP end
points that you can scrape.
If it's a piece of software that
you cannot instrument directly,
we typically have these things
called Exporters that are
little bridges that sit between
Prometheus and the thing you
care about, and translate the
metrics into the Prometheus
format.
So I already mentioned
the Note Exporter,
which translates sys
and procfs metrics
into Prometheus metrics.
Then we have, for example,
a MySQL daemon exporter
that, in the back end, talks
actually SQL queries to a MySQL
daemon, and gets internal
stats about that server,
and translates that
to Prometheus metrics.
And we have by now,
I think over 100
of these integrations in both
in our official organization
and provided by the community.
And they're pretty
easy to write.
They're basically just
a small translation
layers between metric systems.
And then the golden
thing, what we really
recommend is, if you
have services yourselves,
that you build yourself where
you control the code, really
instrument them directly using
one of the client libraries
that we provide, where
you get API object,
such as a counter, a gauge,
histogram, or a summary,
that allow you to track various
states in your own servers,
and exactly the ones that
you actually care about.
So really nice white box
instrumentation of your code.
And that's really how you can
also get the best alerting.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm
curious about something
that you mentioned.
So basically, the
way I understand it,
Prometheus goes in outs,
and goes and scrapes
these HTTP end point on
all the different things
that you have running outside.
But you're also talking about
very dynamic environments.
So something like
Kubernetes, where containers
are going up and down.
Or possibly, environments
where VMs are being created
and destroyed constantly.
How does Prometheus know
when those things are
spun up or been destroyed so it
knows to go and grab that data
from where it needs to?
JULIUS VOLZ: Thank you
for the great question.
This is one of the key
parts of Prometheus
that make it
special, I would say.
It integrates with
service discovery
and with whatever kind
of service discovery
your infrastructure has.
Out of the box, we
currently support roughly 10
different mechanisms.
So these can be ones
where you discover AWS,
or like EC2, or Google
Compute Engine instances,
or so on a host level.
But we also integrate with
some of the cluster schedulers,
like Kubernetes, where we talk
to the Kubernetes API server
to provide us the list of
all the service's end points,
and pods, and so running
on that Kubernetes cluster.
And the nice thing is this kind
of serves multiple purposes.
On one hand, we know then where
we need to go to get metrics.
So you know the actual
HTTP end points.
On the other hand, we know what
should be there in the world.
And if we cannot pull from
it, we know that it's done.
You can base simple health
alerting on this already
on the signal.
And the third thing
which is just really cool
is if you're using a good
service discovery mechanism,
like the one in
Kubernetes for example,
you get a lot of metadata
about the things you discover.
So you don't only
know that there
is an HTTP end point that
you should pull from,
but you also get all the
Kubernetes annotations,
and labels, and other
metadata that you can then
choose to either map
into your time series
or also make decisions on.
You can have an annotation
that says whether to scrape
a target at all or not.
Yeah.
But just mapping the metadata
into your time series
is very nice, because then
you can see this engine x
over there is in environment
equals production instance,
for example.
And then you can use that in
your queries, in your alerts.
So yeah, the service
discovery integration
is something that is pretty
new in monitoring systems,
and has been ignored
in the static world.
I mean, in the static
world, you kind
of just configure
what you expect.
Or often with
push-based systems,
where the instrument
and services themselves
push metrics to the
monitoring system,
the question of what even
should be there in the world
has often just been ignored.
Like if an instance or a
host never reports, then
you might never know
that it's missing.
FRACESC CAMPOY: So I have
a couple of questions now.
You keep on saying this word
"time series" over and over.
And I'm curious about it.
On one side, you say that
you exposed that time series,
that data from every
single one of the elements
that you're monitoring.
What is the format for that?
Is that like JSON,
Particle buffers,
how do you expose that?
Because I guess that
is very important
that that's efficient, right?
JULIUS VOLZ: Yep.
We had JSON at the very
beginning of Prometheus,
and then dumped
that at some point
for, not only, but also
efficiency reasons.
Now we have two
formats, a text based
one, which is very simple to
construct, and nice to read,
and very efficient to parse.
Where basically, the format
contains one time series sample
per line.
And we also have
a protocol buffer
based format, which can be even
more efficient and a bit more
robust, and then can then
easily be implemented
by any protocol buffer parser.
But in reality, there are not
actually many implementations
that need to parse the
protocol, because it's mainly
the Prometheus server
doing that job.
So we really want to
optimize the easy production,
so that you can, even
from a shell script,
really easily just spit
out a metric, and so on.
So the text format seems
to be the one that actually
is getting the most traction.
And some client
libraries don't even
bother implementing the protocol
buffer format at the moment.
FRACESC CAMPOY: So you're
getting all that information
from a lot of different agents.
And I'm assuming
that that's going
to be a decent amount
of data that you
want to store somewhere.
Where do you store it?
What is the database
behind all of this?
JULIUS VOLZ: Right.
Yeah.
Prometheus's data is
highly dimensional.
You're not only getting
from a lot of sources,
but those sources
might sub-differentiate
their own data up by a lot
of labels and dimensions.
Like what CPU did the
CPU usage happen in?
You know, what
mode did it happen?
And so on and so on.
Which file system
did some file system
fullness metric pertain to?
And we store all the data
currently on local disk.
Prometheus itself only knows
how to store local disk.
This is intentional, because
it keeps things simple.
You don't have to run
a clustered distributed
system, which might be the
first one that goes down
in the face of a
network petition
or some other
trouble when you need
your monitoring system the most.
The next question then
is usually, but how
do you keep that
highly available?
The way you do that
is by just running
two identically
configured Prometheus
servers that know exactly
nothing about each other.
They're configured to scrape
exactly the same targets.
There's no history or any kind
of historical state in targets.
The targets really just know
the last value of any metric.
So what the current value.
So you can scrape
them in parallel
by as many Prometheus's as you
want, and it still works out
fine.
And then both of
these servers can
calculate alerting
rules by themselves,
and dispatch alerts
to a component also
of the Prometheus ecosystem,
called the Alert Manager.
And that then actually
de-duplicates these alerts,
and routes them to recipients.
So that does mean that
the local storage isn't
infinitely scalable or durable.
If you lose a node, it's gone.
And you know, if you
lose two nodes and turn,
and they come back up, they
won't backfill from the other.
So for people who do
want to store data
for a really long time with
a guarantee of not losing it,
we recently added a remote,
write, and read back
integration protocol that
people could integrate with.
Where Prometheus
basically sends any sample
that it stores also to a remote
URL that you can specify.
And actually, if your
bridge implements it,
you can also then
read back the data.
So for example, right now
we have an experimental toy
bridge, which knows how to write
data into InfluxDB, which you
can get in a clustered version
in a commercial version,
at least.
And then also read it back again
through PromQL in Prometheus,
but coming from Influx TB.
So now you can nuke your local
database, and still get data.
But we really wanted to decouple
the actual really core alerting
functionality from that
remote storage aspect.
FRACESC CAMPOY:
This really sounds
like a good match for Bigtable.
JULIUS VOLZ: Yep.
FRACESC CAMPOY: I'd like
to see if someone could
implement something like that.
That'd be cool.
JULIUS VOLZ: Well, this
is happening already.
So there is also
cortex from Weaveworks,
which is both an open source
project and a hosted service
by them, which I also
was involved in building.
And this is a
reimplementation of Prometheus
based on currently AWS.
But another company is
working on porting it over
to Google Cloud.
Also Bigtable there, by the way.
And this is multitenant
horizontally scalable durable
forever, and so on.
And you basically configure
your Prometheus locally
to still discover targets
locally, pull targets locally,
but then send all the
collected samples over
to this cloud service.
Or you could run this
yourself as well.
So yeah, that that
kind of already
exists or is being created.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool.
So I'm also just
curious, it looks
like there's a huge
community around Prometheus.
Who's actually using it?
Can you name any customers?
JULIUS VOLZ: Oh, I
have to be careful.
I would have to
look, and especially
to see who I can name publicly.
There are a bunch of Fortune
500 companies, big ones.
I think Walmart Labs has
been reasonably open.
New York Times.
Yeah, several big ones.
Other ones are
thinking about it.
FRACESC CAMPOY: I guess,
SoundCloud is using it?
JULIUS VOLZ: I don't want to
name any names that I shouldn't
name at the moment.
So I would have to check the
list again to make sure that--
MARK MANDEL: I'm just
looking at the web site.
JULIUS VOLZ: Oh, yeah.
The website has
some that explicitly
asked us to add their logo.
But there is many more, and
really big ones as well.
So I think one of
the nice things
for the adoption of
Prometheus that it also
works really nicely
together with Kubernetes.
So Kubernetes is kind of really
inspired by Bork in Google.
There was a tool
inside Google, which
I think is mentioned in the
Google SRE e-book, called
"Borgmon," and that was a big
inspiration for Prometheus.
So there's some analogy
going on between Kubernetes
and Prometheus.
They both use labels
in their data models.
Kubernetes has native
Prometheus metrics.
Prometheus has native support
for Kubernetes's service
discovery.
So they kind of
go together well.
And I think a lot of
ex-Googlers and current Googlers
also noticed that, and picked
it up because of that reason.
So I think that really
helps adoption, as well
as being part of this Cloud
Native Computing Foundation.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Also,
there's something else
that is in common between
Kubernetes and Prometheus,
right?
Which is they're
both written in Go?
JULIUS VOLZ: They're
both written in Go, yes.
Single static binaries.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
Just because I'm super,
super curious as well.
So if I want to install
Prometheus on Kubernetes,
should I install it
in the same cluster
that I'm already running
my other apps in?
Or should I run it in
a different cluster?
FRACESC CAMPOY: Who
monitors Prometheus?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Who monitors the
monitors, right?
JULIUS VOLZ: Yeah.
I think what people
normally do is
they do run their normal
Prometheus in the Kubernetes
cluster, because
that makes it easier
to monitor targets in there.
You automatically get
the necessary credentials
molded into your Kubernetes
pod to be able to talk
to the API server, and so on.
And you also have
immediate network access
to all the instances in the
pods that you need to pull from.
You can and should if you're
serious about monitoring,
then still have some external
meta-monitoring probably
that monitors your
Prometheus servers.
Not only that they're
up, but the Prometheus
server itself also outputs
a lot of instrumentation
in the Prometheus format itself.
So now you can really inspect
with some meta-monitoring
how all your Prometheus
servers are really
behaving, whether they're
overloaded, and so on.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I'm curious about--
since you were talking
about things are in common
in between Kubernetes
and Prometheus.
One of the cool things
about Kubernetes
is that idea of having many
Kubernetes clusters working
together as a federation.
Is there such a
thing for monitoring?
Or is it not necessary?
JULIUS VOLZ: We have a
concept called federation.
It's not exactly the same
as Kubernetes Federation.
The way it works is
that, let's say, you
have 10 data centers, or
10 Kubernetes clusters,
you might have for a
given service in there
or all the services run one
Prometheus server per cluster.
That gives you a very detailed
local view of the universe.
But it might be that not all
the data of all 10 clusters
fits into one big global
Prometheus server.
So you could have
still a federation
set up, where you have a
global Prometheus server, which
scrapes federated data from
all the 10 subordinated
Prometheus's, but only gets kind
of roll-ups or aggregations,
where you maybe sum up over
all the instances of a given
service and don't have the
really detailed data anymore.
So you can keep that global,
but not really detailed
level at the top.
And have local,
but very detailed
data at the bottom of
your federation tree.
And your federation tree could
even have multiple levels.
You can also use federation
to do it kind of sideways.
You know, to pull data from a
Prometheus of a different team
if you're also
interested in that.
Common use case would
be, for example,
if the team that runs
the Kubernetes cluster
has a Prometheus server.
And you have maybe
your own one that
just monitors your direct
service metrics of your one
service running on Kubernetes.
You might be also interested in
externally observed container
resource usage metrics
for your services, right?
So you can pull them from the
other Prometheus server that
is already gathering
all that data
from the built-in
cAdvisors in the cubelets,
and then store that in
your Prometheus server.
Or you could also, if you
have the credentials, even
go out and scrape
that data yourself.
But that's one
possibility as well.
So this allows you to scale
setups and be more flexible.
FRACESC CAMPOY: So I guess we're
kind of running out of time.
But is there any
other topic, anything
that we might have missed
that you'd like to mention?
JULIUS VOLZ: I should
probably mention
that there is a Prometheus
conference happening again
this year, the
second one, PromCon.
The first one was
last year in Berlin.
And the one this year is going
to happen August 17 and 18
in the Google Munich office.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Nice.
JULIUS VOLZ: And the CFP
is currently still open.
So we're still taking talks
until the end of the month.
Head to promcon.io
and submit a talk
if you do anything vaguely
Prometheus-related that
could be interesting.
And if you just
want to attend, we
are going to open ticket sales
probably sometime in June.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Julius, thank you so
much for taking the time
to hang out with us, talking
to us about Prometheus.
I'm definitely going to take
that for a spin sometime soon.
That was really great.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that was interesting.
Thank you very much.
JULIUS VOLZ: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: I really
want to sit down and play
with Prometheus.
I think I'm going to
install it on some clusters
that I'm using, so I
can see exactly what's
going on inside them.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It is a really cool project.
And I really like
that it's open source.
So you know, it's like if you
have a cluster of machines
running anywhere, you
can have now Kubernetes
with GRPC, and Istio, and--
MARK MANDEL: Prometheus.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Prometheus.
And everything is green and go.
So you know, yeah.
I like it.
It's a happy world.
Cool.
So let's move on to our
question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Right.
Yeah.
So this is a fun one.
So the idea here being is
that I built an application.
And maybe I forgot to add some
logging in some places that I
probably should have, right?
Something went wrong.
Maybe I was just a bit rushed.
Who knows, right?
And something is
failing in production.
And I'm thinking to
myself, ah, I really
wish I'd put some
logging in there.
But ideally, I mean, I
could just rewrite the code
and redeploy a new version.
That takes time.
That takes effort.
I'd prefer not to do that.
Is there a way I can magically
just stick some log statements
inside my code and make it run?
FRACESC CAMPOY: No, you should
have written better code.
It is your fault. And
you should feel bad.
MARK MANDEL: I feel bad now.
I'm sorry.
FRACESC CAMPOY: There
is actually a great way.
We talked about this
a long time ago.
But from the of
Stackdriver debugger,
which is a really
awesome tool that
works on most environments in
most languages, except for Go
on AppEngine.
Other than that, pretty
much works everywhere.
So if you're using Node.js,
or Python, or Java, or Go,
you should check it out.
Probably works.
Probably works?
It works.
So what you can do
is you can go and set
a breakpoint in the line
that you care about,
you want to learn more about.
What are the values of all
the variables at this point?
If you did this for real, like
you actually put a break point,
then you're actually stopping
your processing production,
and that's a big no.
So that's not what happens.
What happens is that we take
a snapshot of the whole call
stack and the heap.
So you can actually see
what are the variables, what
are the values for every
single one of those variables.
Now, the problem is that if you
do this, what you're getting
is every single time
there is a new snap shot,
you get to see it.
And you inspect it
manually, right?
And sometimes this is
not what you want to do.
Sometimes what you want to do
is see a log of, not only ones,
but all of the times that
someone goes in an actual log.
So then you can analyze it
with all the log analysis tools
that you might already have.
MARK MANDEL: And I
can see the history
and exactly what's going on.
FRACESC CAMPOY: This is
actually very useful, right?
So literally everything
you want to do
is just add one line of logs,
and you can actually do that.
It's what we call
debug log points.
And it is as simple as
going to the debugger,
clicking on the line number.
And rather than adding a
breakpoint, what you are
is a log point.
And then you can
write a little--
it's basically a
line of code, that
basically says if
some condition, then
log some expression.
That it.
It's very simple.
But that's exactly
what you want.
Super effective.
There's a really good video
by our dear colleague Aja
Hammerly.
It's one of these Cloud Minutes.
So in less than 60
seconds, you learn
how to use it, in
her case for Python,
but it is pretty much the
same case for every language.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So now I can add logging
statements anywhere
I want inside my executing code.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Actually, yeah.
I mean, then there's the
point of at what point?
Because those logs
will be there, but then
when redeploy they go away.
But then should you have
the log in your code base?
MARK MANDEL: I feel
like this is stuff
I would put in an emergency,
and then go back and review
what is the right amount of
logs to have in my things,
so that in future
cases, maybe something
else goes wrong or
something other thing wrong
I can track it.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Once I've
done my post mortem,
and my blame free analysis,
and all that kind of stuff.
FRACESC CAMPOY:
Blame free analysis.
That's the important part.
Cool.
So I guess that
answers the question.
This is almost the
end of the episode.
But before that, so
you're finally back.
MARK MANDEL: I am.
FRACESC CAMPOY:
What are you up to?
MARK MANDEL: So I'm staying
in San Francisco for a while,
which I'm super happy about.
A little bit of travel less.
But it looks like I'm
going to be at Next New
York on the 18th of July.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: I'll be talking
about gaming and GCP, details
to be determined.
But looks like
that's going ahead.
So that should be
lots and lots of fun.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Is it
going to be related somehow
to the blog post that you wrote
on how to run video games,
and Kubernetes, and
stuff like that?
MARK MANDEL: It's
entirely possible.
At this point,
actually, I'm not sure.
So we'll see.
FRACESC CAMPOY: In those cases,
normally you say, it's secret.
MARK MANDEL: It's secret?
FRACESC CAMPOY: It's secret.
It's confidential for now.
MARK MANDEL: OK, fair enough.
I can neither confirm nor deny.
Excellent.
And what are you up to
Just For Funk stuff?
FRACESC CAMPOY: Yes.
I just published my
latest Just For Funk.
Actually, I published
two, because I was so late
in the previous one.
They ended up going
up almost together.
But yeah, one was about cgo.
And the one that I
published last weekend,
it's a really cool one,
running a Twitter bod green
and go with systemd, and on
Google Cloud platform for free.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Yep.
So it was like we talked about
all the free tier and stuff
like that a couple times.
F1-micros are free, and they're
tiny, but they're big enough.
So yeah, it is a
pretty cool episode.
And then after
that, I'm actually
preparing my workshop
for Go Tooling
In Action that will take place
in New York for QCon, QCon New
York, which is in two weeks.
So that is the
last week of June,
which is the week of the 26.
I'll be there for
the whole week.
It's going to be awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Francesc, thank you
so much for joining me
for yet another episode.
FRACESC CAMPOY: Thank you,
Mark, for coming back finally.
I hope your dog is happy.
MARK MANDEL: She is very happy.
Thanks to all our
listeners as well.
And we'll see you all next week.
FRACESC CAMPOY: See
you all the next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]